let's talk about inner the interference
effect and concurrent training a little
bit let's do it um
the road to athens segment of the last
podcast was a hit
there were multiple people and and by
that i mean two or potentially three
people
uh who asked for more concurrent
training content on the podcast
uh so is that a representative sample of
our listeners probably not but let's uh
let's meet their needs right now let's
do it
uh so
the title of the article i wrote was
does the interference effect get larger
as training status increases
title of the study i reviewed was
development of maximal dynamic strength
during concurrent resistance and
endurance training
in untrained moderately trained and
trained individuals a systematic review
and meta-analysis by petri and
colleagues
um
so in in this uh meta-analysis
i mean you you can probably tell what
they did just from the title uh they
started with a systematic literature
search they uh identified studies with
um
healthy subjects between 18 and 40 years
old um
the group the studies needed to compare
a group performing uh both lower body
resistance training and endurance
training versus a group doing an
identical resistance training program
but no endurance training uh the
subjects all needed to have the same
training status
uh
resistance training needed to occur at
least twice per week at uh a 10 at an
intensity of at least 60 percent of 1rm
the endurance training needed to
at least be of moderate intensity
so not like walking programs or anything
like that
and the studies needed to report changes
in maximal squat or leg press strength
those were the inclusion criteria they
found 27 studies um
all of which were judged to be of either
moderate to high quality
uh seven seven studies were on untrained
subjects ten were on moderately trained
subjects
and uh ten were on trained subjects i'll
note that i don't necessarily agree with
the uh the researchers characterization
of untrained versus moderately trained
in this study so
they categorized a study as being on
moderately trained subjects if the
subjects um
were reported as being active
so
you'd only be counted as untrained if
they reported that like people were
completely sedentary if someone was
described as recreationally active but
not participating in resistance training
they'd still count them as moderately
trained for this meta-analysis i don't
necessarily agree with that but uh yeah
because i mean a lot of times for
studies that are sampling like uh
college students for example which is a
huge
percentage of studies it's like ah
you're a college student you go to class
every day you know maybe you play
kickball twice a week
yeah yeah yeah yeah so uh i functionally
just view it as train versus untrained i
i don't like the the untrained versus
moderately trained distinction that they
made in this study uh but anyway that's
what they did that's the nomenclature
i'll use moving forward
so just be aware that when i say
moderately trained i'm talking untrained
but but fairly active
um so anyway they ran the meta three
different ways um
first they just looked at all effect
sizes from all studies
second they looked at uh just studies
where
the endurance and resistance training
were performed in the same session so
you know you show up at the gym you run
for 30 minutes and then you lift or you
show up at the gym you lift and then you
run for 30 minutes
all in one session and then the third
way they ran it was just looking at
studies where
the endurance and resistance training
took place in different sessions so they
could have been on different days they
could have been uh on the same day but
like you lift in the morning run in the
evening or vice versa um so they they
looked at it in
in those uh three different ways
so in in their first meta analysis when
it was just all effect sizes from all
studies they found that for untrained
subjects
concurrent training led to strength
gains that were just as large as only
doing resistance training
for moderately trained subjects there
also wasn't a statistically significant
effect but there was an effect size of
0.2 p value of 0.08 uh favoring
resistance training only for strength
gains and then for trained subjects
there was a there was a significant
effect small effect size uh cohen's d
0.35 and that was statistically
significant so basically you see this
pattern where
the magnitude of the interference effect
or stated another way the superiority of
just doing resistance training versus
concurrent training uh got
larger and larger as training status
increased such that there was virtually
no effect for sedentary individuals and
a
small but statistically significant
effect for trained individuals
so moving on in the studies where
endurance and resistance training were
performed in the same training session
a similar pattern emerged but the effect
sizes were larger particularly for the
trained subjects so for untrained
individuals again virtually no effect
for moderately trained subjects you see
a
small to trivial effect again cohen's d
of 0.23 and again not quite
statistically significant p value of
0.14 but then for the trained subjects
you you're seeing now a pretty notable
effect size of 0.66 um that's generally
termed a moderate effect
not quite bordering on a large effect
which is typically
typically going to be 0.8 uh with with
the standard cutoffs but that's that's a
relatively hefty moderate effect
so
especially for trained subjects when
you're doing concurrent training with
both
endurance training and lifting in the
same session there seems to be a pretty
negative effect on strength outcomes
that's not to say you'll get weaker you
will continue getting stronger but
probably at a notably slower rate than
you would have if you were just lifting
and not doing endurance training uh and
then finally um when they uh just looked
at studies where endurance and
resistance training were
performed in separate sessions either
separate times on the same day or on
different days they actually found no
significant effect regardless of
training status so it seemed that just
separating out the stimuli
basically completely did away with the
interference effect such that concurrent
training was just as effective for
strength development as only doing
strength training was
uh so i'll note i do think that um
in a meta-analysis like this where we're
basically you're just looking at
two training variables like did you just
lift weights or did you lift weights and
also do cardio you're missing out on
some degree of nuance like you're you're
not you're basically not able to look to
see if the dose makes the poison uh as
it were so
you know i i wouldn't
i would not be an absolutist on this
topic and say like look man like
if you're trying to
win usa
usapl nationals and also complete an
ultra marathon and train for both at the
same time you're definitely not going to
have a negative effect on your strength
gains i i don't think that that's a
justifiable take most of these studies
use
pretty moderate levels of endurance
training in them so i i think the
average uh frequency and duration was
like 30 minutes of about 30 minutes of
cardio about three times per week so
like that level of endurance training
when combined with resistance training
if you're doing the endurance training
and resistance training in separate
sessions doesn't seem to have a negative
effect on strength development
but if you did considerably more
endurance training it probably would
but at least this meta-analysis doesn't
really give us any clues for where that
threshold lies
and the other thing i'll note
just
related to this meta-analysis
is when people talk about concurrent
training
the first study they generally bring up
and for good reason uh is a study by
hixson from 1980. uh this this is kind
of the granddaddy of them all in the
concurrent training literature title is
interference of strength development by
simultaneous
by simultaneously training for strength
and endurance so the title of this study
is where the term interference effect
comes from uh the study was from 1980 it
was the first study um
rigorously looking at the interference
effect and whether concurrent training
uh had negative effects on strength
development
and so yeah this is the first study that
people tend to cite
um
and
it has a pretty
large effect so
um in this meta-analysis the hixson
study
the the effect in favor of resistance
training only over endurance training
was about 0.61
and the subjects in that study were
moderately trained which
again i would probably refer to as
untrained so when you look at the total
batch of effect sizes from studies on
moderately trained or untrained subjects
in this meta-analysis
the pooled effect size for all of those
is about 0.1
and the hixon study i believe had the
either the largest or second largest
effect size of any study that had been
done
and the effect size for that was about
six times larger than the pooled effect
size
of the other studies on untrained and
moderately trained subjects so it's
it's very not representative of the body
of literature um which isn't a knock on
it but this relates to something we've
talked about on the podcast before
and that is
when a body of literature is just
developing you shouldn't necessarily
assume that the average effect seen in
the first couple of studies in the area
are is going to be representative of
where kind of the pooled effect estimate
will wind up once more research is done
and it can go in both directions so the
typical way it goes is that early effect
estimates are quite a bit larger than
the eventual
kind of pooled effect estimate that a
body of literature settles on uh and and
the reason for that is
well there are several reasons for that
but one of the biggest ones
is that most early research in a
particular area is just kind of like
proof of concept research where
if you are
hickson you're an enterprising
researcher in 1980 and you think that
doing concurrent training will lead
to smaller strength gains than just
doing resistance training if that is
your assumption
what you need to do is you need to
publish research showing
that this is an area of research that
warrants further study and so you're
essentially trying you're trying to
design a study that will find a positive
effect to validate the need for further
research and so i i don't have the the
details in front of me right now but if
memory serves the endurance training
protocol in the hixson study
was one of the more challenging
endurance training protocols that has
been done in any concurrent training
study up to this point so it was
basically designed to find an effect and
then once that effect was found future
studies have kind of used more
uh kind of more chill more
representative i suppose endurance
training protocols and have found
considerably smaller effects
sometimes it can work in the opposite
direction as well so for example
if say a supplement comes on the market
and they find that
maybe this has a small positive effect
it could it could turn out to be that
like a different form of the supplement
could be more effective uh it could be
that the dose used in the
first studies was too small and so you
could see an increase in the pooled
effect estimate over time but
uh the key point is just that like if
there's only one or two studies in a
body of literature um
it very well could be the case that the
effect they're seeing is a real effect
but the magnitude of the effect being
reported may not necessarily be
representative of where that body of
literature will end up